[Musique]
au revoir Mirel Jourda bonjour Bruno
retillo merci beaucoup d'être notre
invité politique ce matin sénateur de la
vandé président du groupe les
républicains ici au Sénat on va bien sûr
longuement parler du projet de loi
immigration hier soir le Sénat a donc
supprimé l'article 3 sur la
régularisation des travailleurs dans les
métiers en tension c'était votre ligne
rouge mais même si certains critères
sont plus durs il y a quand même un
article sur les régularisation est-ce
que du coup c'est une victoire politique
en trompleœil pour vous ah non c'est une
victoire politique on l'a bien vu
d'ailleurs hier puisque le ministre a
donné un avis très défavorable à notre
amendement qui supprimait l'article 3
ensuite toute la soirée la gouuchche
s'est battue à la fois contre la
suppression de cet article 3 et elle
s'est batue ensuite contre notre
amendement qui rétablissait je vais en
parler donc dans quelques instants un
article qui durcit les règles de la
circulaire Vals et puis dernière preuve
monsieur Sacha oulier qui ce matin dans
Le Figaro dit mais jamais jamais on
votera cela et on rétablira le texte
initial voilà comment vous réagissez on
va revenir après dans le détail mais
comment vous réagissez à cette
déclaration de Sacha alier ce matin qui
balait d'un revers de main l'accord au
Sénat et le texte du Sénat c'est la
preuve de ce que je dis depuis le départ
l'article 3 ça a été un condensé du en
même temps macronien c'était un gage à
l'aile gauche de la macronie un gage de
laxisme et ce gage de laxisme je n'ai
pas fait de fétichisme numérologique
c'est pas parce que le chiffre 3 qui est
par ailleurs un très beau chiffre me
convenait pas c'est simplement que le
l'article 3 donnait un droit automatique
c'est-à-dire que vous frudez vous entrez
clandestinement euh sur le territoire
français vous n'en avez pas le droit
mais vous frudez et plus vous fraudez
dans le temps plus cette fraude est
dissimulée et plus vous allez acquérir
un droit qui sera un droit opposable à
l'administration donc automatique à être
régularisé la fraude paye c'est pas
possible en droit français mais vous
avez dit lundi dans votre discours
d'ouverture que vous vouliez pas ouvrir
de brèche à l'immigration illégale d'où
ce souhait supprimer l'article 3 sauf
qu'il y a quand même un article donc il
y aura quand même des régularisations de
gens arrivés en situation illégale en
quoi ça ouvre pas de brèche je vais vous
expliquer dès lors qu'on supprimait
l'article 3 et l'article 4 j'espère
qu'on en parlera aussi c'est pas que
l'article 3 qui a été supprimé on se
retrouvait dans la dans la condition du
droit réglementaire d'une circulaire
Vals de la régularisation aujourd'hui la
circulaire Vals permet de régulariser à
peu près 7000 personnes notamment en
matière de travail bien si donc on
retombait sur cette circulaire Vals il
fallait absolument endurcir les critères
parce que sinon ça voulait dire que on
acceptait les critères de la circulaire
Vals mais pourquoi ne pas avoir demandé
la suppression de la circulaire Vals
dans ce cas ah parce qu'il faut de toute
façon forcément régularisé au
comptegoutte mais quand vous avez des
gens qui sont méritants dans des métiers
qui sont vraiment tension moi ça ne me
choque pas ça toujours été le cas sur
tous les gouvernements tous les
présidents de la République en revanche
ce que je voulais c'est apporter un
certain nombre de modifications d'abord
première chose notre article proclame
tout haut qu'il n'y aura pas du tout de
régularisation automatique il y a pas de
droit opposable et puis on a durci à
quatre niveaux premier niveau il fallait
dans la circulaire Val travailler 8 mois
sur 24 mois on augmente de 50 % cette
durée on passe de 8 mois à 12 mois pour
pouvoir prétendre au premier critère
2ème chose très important fondamentale
on va pas demander au préfet de
contrôler uniquement l'activité
professionnelle on va lui demander de
bien regarder à
360° les qualités de l'individu s'il
doit si j'ose dire respecter l'ordre
publique s'il n'a pas été condamné si
bien sûr il respecte les critères et
notamment les valeurs de la République
et cetera et cetera donc c'est ça qui
est important pour voir si il est
vraiment intégrable et enfin bien sûr
c'est l'employé qui va déclencher la
procédure mais dès lors que l'employé
mais qui est clandestin l'aura déclenché
l'administration sen saisie et va aller
faire un contrôle de l'activité réelle
pourquoi parce que c'est très facile de
produire des fausses fiches de paye le
l'article 3 c'était une machine non
seulement à régulariser mais c'est une
machine à frauder et enfin euh c'est
expérimental on a donné une sorte de
date de préemption à le 31 décembre 2026
ce qui nous permettra de voir
d'expertiser pour corriger s'il le
fallait et sur l'article 4 puisqu'on va
en parler c'est c'était aussi ligne
rouge he cétait 34 sur le travail des
demandeurs d'asile et qui autorisait
certains demandeurs d'asile à pouvoir
travailler dès le dépôt de leur demande
pourquoi l'avoir supprimé parce que
c'était là encore le symbole de l'appel
d'air vous avez en Europe trois types de
pays c'està dire que là c'est pas le
droit d'asile en tant que tel c'est
l'accès du demandeur d'asile qui arrive
sur le sol français et qui euh va
accéder au marché de l'emploi il y a des
pays qui font 9 mois il faut attendre 9
mois pour pouvoir avoir un emploi bien
il y a des pays qui font 6 mois et nous
on serait dans le petit tout petit club
des pays qui serait le plus laxiste au
premier jour vous pouvez travailler et
avec l'article 3 vous travaillez ensuite
admettons que vous n'êtes pas vous êtes
débouté vous n'avez pas votre statut de
réfugié vous pouvez au bout d'un certain
temps vous faire régulariser donc on
voit bien que la France se situait dans
non pas dans la moyenne des pays
européens mais elle se situait parmi les
pays européens les plus laxistes c'est
pas possible nous on veut reprendre le
contrôle de l'immigration et par
conséquent nous voulons des messages de
fermeté aucune brèche nulle part
sauf que Gérald haranin hier en séance
il a dit que l'essentiel était préservé
et qu'il y aura quand même des
régularisations est-ce qu'il y a pas un
loup politique du coup non non mais
attendez là vous on était sur l'article
4 on revient sur sur l'article 3 mais
sur sur
sur Géral daranin sur cet accord qui a
été signé avec les centristes mais
pourquoi donc pourquoi alors Géral
Darmanin s'est opposé à la suppression
de l'article 3 pourquoi la gauche toute
la nuit nous a dit mais non non et
pourquoi il dit que c'est un compromis
acceptable mais mais tout simplement
parce que Géral Armin son souci on le
voit bien avec monsieur sachaoulier qui
représente l' gauche mais qui est en
même temps le François Noël buffet de
l'Assemblée nationale le président de la
commission des lois ça n'est pas rien
c'est dans sa commission que les députés
examineront le texte et bien monsieur
Darmanin il doit concilier
l'inconciliable il est dans le en même
temps il faut qu'il fasse croire à ses
députés que finalement il aura été battu
au Sénat nous l'avons battu hier soir
puisque nous avons supprimé l'article 3
mais que c'est pas très grave c'est
comme si finalement c'était la même
chose on change le numéro d'article mais
le contenu est le même tu parles donc
pour vous c'est l'inverse c'est une
belle victoire très franchement très
franchement il y a 48 heur vousz dit que
ça se serait terminé comme ça je vous
aurais pas cru ça a été dur B bien sûr
ça compromis avec les centristes c'est
c'est pas tellement parce qu'on a de
bonne relation avec Hervé Marseille mais
c'est beaucoup plus que la majorité
sénatoriale qu'est ce qui se joue vous
savez que 74 % des Français de tout bord
ne veulent plus d'immigration en tout
cas ils considèrent qu'il y a trop
d'immigration ce qui est nouveau c'est
que même les sympathisants de LFI de
l'extrême gauche sont plus nombreux à
dire qu'il y a trop d'immigration que à
ceux qui pensent qu'encore que c'est une
chance pour la France donc nous et moi
je me sentais comptable de ça je ne
voulais pas entraîner le Sénat dans un
texte qui l' encore aurait exagéré la
vague migratoire c'est cette bataille
qui se joue aujourd'hui et si on perdait
cette bataille on déroule un tapis rouge
à Madame Le Pen tous les laxises que
j'ai entendu hier hier soir ce sont
finalement quelque part les idiots
utiles de ceux qui pourraient demain
faire le jeu de cette montée J justement
des partis populistes et démagogues
est-ce que vous avez la garantie que les
républicains de l'Assemblée vous
suivront et suivront la version de votre
texte ben maintenant les choses sont un
peu assez clair en tout cas puisque
monsieur Houlier dit on va détricoter le
texte du Sénat nous
rétablirons le texte de l'exé on va
parler de sachaouier mais lesair de
l'Assemblée est-ce qu'ils vont vous
soutenir non mais le texte va être
détricoté donc nous on va observer d'ici
mais eux à chaque détricotage ils
pointeront du doigt précisément les
abandons et vous êtes sur la même ligne
et on est absolument sur la même ligne
et je dis je vais au-delà vous savez
qu'une loi c'est un match en trois
manches il y a le Sénat il y a
l'Assemblée nationale et il y aura une
commission mixte paritaire SEP députés
se sénateurs parce que il y aura pas
d'accord dans un premier temps entre les
deux chambres croyez-moi si le texte il
est détricoté ce sera niet on va on va
parler de la troisème manche mais sur la
deè pour revenir à cette interview de
Sacha alier qui en plein examen du texte
au Sénat dit déjà qu'il ne tiendra pas
compte de votre version et qu'il
rétablira le texte ambitieux de
l'exécutif sur l'immigration c'est ce
qu'il dit comment vous jugez cette
interview elle est méprisante là je
pense qu'il a fait une faute de carart
politique on peut parfaitement s'opposer
mais si comme je le pense il est attaché
au
parlementarisme au procédures
parlementaires tout simplement il aurait
dû attendre je pense que en plein texte
alors même que nous n'avons pas voté le
texte prendre une position en disant ce
que fait le Sénat peu importe on
s'assoit dessus on le détricotera bon
ben en précisant que c'est de toute
façon c'est l'assemblée qui a le dernier
mot c'est une faute on verra bien on
verra bien qui se méfie parce qu'il y a
pas de majorité absolue à l'Assemblée
nationale ceci dit pour moi c'est en
quelque sorte une nouvelle preuve la
preuve que ce que nous avons fait avec
les centristes cet accord là c'est la
sortie vers le haut parce que si cet
accord était simplement une façon de
camoufler une rédition camoufler le fait
que on recycle sur un autre numéro euh
le fameux article 3 jamais Sacha Houlier
ne l'aurait dit c'est bien parce qu'il
était piqué au vif c'est bien parce que
il voit ce que nous sommes en train de
faire ce que nous avons fait c'est donc
la suppression d'article 3 l'article 4
c'est donc le durcissement catégorique
de la circulaire Vals et on a passé pour
l'instant une douzaine de nos marqueurs
extrêmement puissant qui vont envoyer
des signaux à toutes les mafias à toutes
les filières de passeur comme quoi
aujourd' jourd'hui l'immigration
illégale n'est pas la bienvenue en
France sur la troisème man justement sur
la CMP la réunion entre députés et
sénateur est-ce que vous pensez vraiment
qu'il y aura un compromis possible bon
si j'en crois monsieur Sacha Houlier non
donc comment on en sort ah ben les
choses sont très claires le texte est
détricoté il va en commission mixte
permanente où nous on gagne c'est-à-dire
où on réétablit ce qui aura été déricoté
à l'Assemblée et alors on peut le voter
mais si c'est un texte une fois de plus
du en même temps un faux semblant pas
question de tromper les Français pas
question de tricher on s'opposera à ce
texte à quel compromis êtes-vous prêt
vous en commission mixte paritaire sur
l'article 3 on comprend que c'est une
ligne rouge est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
un compromis sur l'aide médicale d'État
non non aucun compromis non mais
attendez mais dans une négociation il
faut bien un peu lâcher de l'Est
Monsieur R su rien je je vais vous
expliquer notre ligne aujourd'hui la
France euh est submergée par un chaos
migratoire nous voulons y mettre fin les
Français veulent y mettre fin bien pour
y mettre fin il faut être inflexible il
peut pas y avoir de brèche et ce que
nous essayons de faire c'est d'amener la
France à être non pas parmi les pays les
mieux disant un des pays qui offre le
plus avantage aux immigrés légaux ou
illégaux à travers le regroupement
familiale à travers l'accès gratuit aux
soins et cetera et cetera y compris la
naturalisation ce que nous voulons c'est
amener la France à une moyenne des pays
européens pour que la France ne soit pas
justement la mieux disante l'aide
médicale d'État mais vous savez que la
plus ENF pratiquement la totalité des
pays européens pratique une
Amu quand j'entends mes collègues y
compris des médecins dire mais attendez
mais ce que fait le Sénat c'est horrible
il y aura des problèmes de pandémie il y
aura des problèmes de santé publique
mais attendez mais avant 99 quand la a
été voté par la gauche d'ailleurs est-ce
que avant il y avait des problèmes de
pandémie est-ce qu'en Allemagne et
ailleurs dans tous les autres pays
européens qui ne pratiquent pas la me
est-ce qu'il y a des problèmes de santé
publique bien sûr que
encore une fois ce sont des appels d'air
ce sont des brèches donc pas question de
laisser mourir les gens pas question de
laisser une femme qui est enceinte qui
va accoucher dans la rue c'est pas ça
notre projet c'est simplement de
remettre la France dans la moyenne des
pays européens pour pass se faire
remarquer parce que sinon les filières
ceux qui pratiquent la traite des êtres
humains connaissent exactement les
législations ils vont orienter les
nouvelles vagues migratoires qui seront
encore plus fortes à l'avenir mais ça ça
on comprend mais si vous nêtes prêt a
aucun compromis il y a un risque la la
CMP échoue et que du coup il n'y ait pas
de texte euh est-ce que c'est pas risqué
il y aura toujours un texte oui il y
aura un texte mais qui sera pas le vôtre
en 2018 mais est-ce que c'est pas risqué
politiquement pour vous parce que vous
aurez un texte moins ferme que ce que
vous auriez pu espérer en lâchant un peu
de l'Est écoutez vous avez une bonne
mémoire en 2018 la loi Colom et j'étais
exactement interrogé dans le mêm terme
la loi colombe disait oui mais ça durcit
par exemple la durée de rétention très
bien mais ça élargit les capacités du
regroupement familial notamment pour les
mineurs non accompagnés on l'avait voté
en première lecture au Sénat et on l'a
refusé d'abord en CMP et on a voté
contre ce texte heureusement qu'on a
voté contre ce texte c'était en 2018
l'année d'après la France battait
malheureusement tous les records qu'on n
jamais connu sur l'migration donc nous
avions eu raison et bien là c'est pareil
moi ce que je veux c'est le bien du pays
je ne raisonne pas en fonction des
intérêts politiciens comme certains peut
le faire et à droite ou à gauche ou au
centre ce que moi je veux c'est un texte
utile qui nous permet de reprendre la
maîtrise des outils juridiques qu'on a
abandonné depuis longtemps qui nous
permettent de réguler l'immigration donc
où ces outilslà sonont dans le texte ou
s'ils n'y sont pas ce sera non un
dernier mot sur l'immigration puisque
Emmanuel Macron a écrit au président de
parti dimanche soir pour dire qu'il
était ouvert à un élargissement de des
critères du référendum pour permettre un
référendum sur les questions de
politique migratoire c'est une main
tendue envers vous ça ce sont des mots
ce sont des mots
alors des mot qui son non mais ce sont
des mots qui si sonnent juste à nos
oreilles parce que je pense que il faut
permettre aux Français de se déterminer
pour deux raisons la première raison
c'est que il y a pas un phénomène qui
est autant bouleversé depuis un
demi-siècle la société française sans
que les Français n'ai jamais été
consultés puis surtout les résultats
d'un référendum s'imposent au Conseil
constitutionnel Vox popoui Vox di h bien
donc ça c'est fondamental maintenant
avec Emmanuel Macron il y a toujours
très très loin des mots aux actes très
très loin et vous savez très bien que
pour trouver alors qu'il y a même pas de
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée pour
trouver une majorité renforcée de 3/5e
sur une question très importante où on
va se déchirer parce que certains
voudont non seulement la migration mais
d'autres domaines et d'autres beaucoup
moins certains voudront qu'il y ait des
initiatives citoyennes et d'autres pas
je n'y crois pas donc pour vous ça
n'aboutira pas cette ég je n'y crois pas
j'es ceci dit j'espère me tromper je si
demain Emmanuel Macron propose un texte
où il y a la
capacité de se retourner vers les
français pour un référendum sur l'
migration je dirais oui mais très
franchement je je je n'y crois pas du
tout Gérard arché et brune PIV ont t
appelé à une marche civique contre
l'antisémitisme dimanche et la présence
la participation du rassemblement
national divise la classe politique hier
ils ont annoncé qu'il ne marcherait pas
au côté du rassemblement national est-ce
que pour vous la présence du RN est un
problème moi je suis stupéfait de cette
polémique parce qu'on est en train
d'oublier cette initiative que je veux
saluer de Gérard archer et de yelmond
pivé le ministre de l'Intérieur hier aux
questions d'actualité nous a donné un
chiffre stupéfiant depuis le 7 octobre
1154 agression antisémite en France soit
en un mois trois fois plus je crois que
dans toute l'année 2022 vous vous rendez
compte et on est en train de se perdre
sur une polémique politicienne cette
marche-là tous les Français sont
bienvenus quel que soi leurs origines
quel que soi leurs croyances quel que
soi leurs appartenances politiques peu
importe je défilerai non pas au côté de
Madame Le Pen mais au côté de Gérard
Larcher et de Madame yel bonneprivé ce
qui est terrible voyez c'est qu'en plus
on tombe dans un panneau un panneau qui
a été tendu aussi par Monsieur Mélenchon
qui a pris le prétexte de la présence du
rassemblement national pour s'exonérer
de sa propre présence tout simplement
parce que je parle de prétexte puisque
lui euh il a parlé de prétexte dans
en indant que il condamnait cette marche
parce que c'était le soutien des amis
inconditionnels du massacre mais le
massacre c'est le Hamas souvenez le
tweet qu'il avait fait odieux contre
madame yelbron Pivet où il l'accusait
justement de massacre mais le massacre
c'est le Hamas et là encore ce que je
veux dénoncer c'est ça le scandale
est-ce que vous avez oublié justement
que Monsieur Mélenchon et ses amis il y
a quelques années en
2019 batit le pavé avait pas refusé
d'aller à cette marche qui était
encouragée par le CCF c'était des islamo
gauchistes et cette marche il y avait
des crit Allah Akbar c'est ça qui est
absolument scandaleux l'antisémitisme a
muté en France mais qu'est-ce que vous
voulez dire juste est-ce qu'il y a une
forme est-ce qu'il y a une forme
d'antisémitisme à la France insoumise
mais mais mais bien sûr l'antisémitisme
s'est longtemps nourri sur le terraau de
l'extrême droite en France ça n'est plus
le fascisme aujourd'hui en France qui
est le terreau de l'antisémitisme
c'estislam
c'est l'islamuchisme m sous le masque de
l'antisionisme je l'affirme sous le
masque de l'antisionisme bien sûr bien
sûr et du coup refuser rendez compte ce
qu'a fait le Hamas en coupant deux des
enfants en détenant des des des des
vieillard comme otage je sais que le
plus jeune je crois otage doit avoir 9
ou 10 mois vous vous rendez compte
couvrir cette barbarie il s'en rendre
complice on a compris votre position sur
la France insoumise mais du coup sur le
rassemblement national quand on a Jordan
Bardella qui dimanche soir dit je ne
crois pas que Jean-Marie Le Pen soit
antisémite est-ce que c'est pas un
problème qu'il soit présent dimanche
prochain à cette marche non mais ça
cette déclaration évidemment que jamais
il aurait dû la faire ce que je vais
vous dire moi c'est que on parlait tout
à l'heure de la proposition du
référendum de Monsieur Macron elle est
née où cette proposition elle est née de
la rencontre de Saint-Denis il a
organisé une rencontre avec toutes les
tous les chefs de partis est-ce qu'il a
refusé monsieur Bardella monsieur
Bardella vous l'avez aperçu il était
dans le tour de table pire même je vais
vous
dire les proches de Monsieur Macron
n'ont cessé dans les commentaires fait à
la presse de tresser des couronnes de
laurier à Monsieur Bardella voilà donc
où on considère que le rassemblement
national n'est pas un parti républicain
alors faut le dissoudre et ça serait
stupide ou alors est-ce que vous voulez
ils défileront de leur côté ils sont
dans la manifestation mais moi oublion
ces ques politiciennes ENF mais dans le
même temps Olivier verrand dit au nom du
gouvernement lui que c'est un problème
la présence du rassemblement national à
7 Olivier verérrant peut-être mais
Olivier verérrant c'est c'est Olivier
verérrant point final voilà il oublie
qu'il y a l'antisémitisme et ces gens-là
se perdent dans des corelles
politiciennes est-ce qu'on peut pas
avoir un peu d'unité nationale sur
quelque chose qui est gravissime
l'antisémitisme chacun devrait se sentir
un peu juif voyez quand on touche à un
juif on touche aux français quand on
touche euh à nos compatriotes c'est à
nous qu'on touche sans doute on dit pas
la même religion peu importe on n'est
pas français à mesure de sa religion sa
croyance de ses origines on est français
parce qu'on est français point final on
aime la France donc chaque Français doit
se sentir concerné parce que nos
compatriotes Français juifs sont d'abord
des Français vous avez rappelé le
chiffre donné hier par Gérald haranin au
question d'actualité 1159 acte
antisémite depuis le 7 octobre vous
l'avez dit c'est trois fois plus que
l'année 2022 et sur le profil des
auteurs ils sont de plus en plus jeunes
c'est ce que vous a dit hier Gérald qui
s'est dit prêt à détailler devant vous
le profil de ces auteurs est-ce que vous
souhaitez qu'il soit auditionné Gérald
harmanin sur cette résurgence de
l'antisémitisme mais il le sera il le
sera je sais qu'il le sera dans le cadre
vablement de la commission des lois il
faut absolument comprendre il faut il
faut comprendre et il faut qu'on ait le
constat justement d'où viennent ces
actes pour que on en tire d'abord un
consensus sur le constat le diagnostic
et et essayer d'en tirer des remèdes
ensuite il se reditionn quand et dans
quel cadre est-ce qu'il faut aller
jusqu'à une commission d'enquête sur
cette résurgence de l'antisémitisme on
on a un certain nombre d'outils de toute
façon euh l'audition peut se dérouler en
dehors d'une commission d'enquête on
verra ça vous souhaitez pas pour le
moment bon écoutez attendons le constat
hein on a déclenché une autre commission
d'enquête sur le narcotrafic qui est
aussi un un énorme problème qui menace
la sécurité la tranquillité de notre
pays mais on essaie de faire face à
l'ensemble des problèmes oui un mot on
va revenir sur la commission d'enquête
sur le narcotrafic mais pour terminer
sur ce qui se passe en Israël
aujourd'hui il y a une conférence
humanitaire qui aura lieu à l'Élysée à
l'initiative d'Emmanuel Macron pour
aider notamment les les civils dans la
bande de Gaza c'est une bonne initiative
bien sûr c'est une bonne initiative je
pense qu'on peut parfaitement être au
côté d'Israël on peut parfaitement
vouloir l'éradication de ce mouvement
islamiste terroriste qui est le Hamas
mais rappelez quand même qu'il y a un
droit international un droit humanitaire
et qu'il ne faut pas le négliger sur la
commission d'enquête sur le narcotrafic
puisque elle a été lancée quel est
l'objectif qui allez-vous auditionner
vous savez cette commission d'enquête
c'est tout simplement que le narcotrafic
en France les Français l'ignorent est en
train de de prendre une dimension
incroyable il y a un échec successif des
différents gouvernements et de ce
gouvernement en particulier moi j'étais
stupéfait en Vendé de de voir et
d'apprendre un beau jour que dans une
toute petite commune voyez de quelques
centaines d'habitants il y avait des
tenanciers d'un d'un bar restaurant qui
était en lien direct avec l'Afrique du
Sud et qui trafiquait ça imprène pas
seulement les banlieux pas seulement les
grandes villes ça imprègne tout le
territoire français l'office français
justement pour la lutte contre les
stupéfiants nous apprend que 80 % des
règlements de compte aujourd'hui en
France à Marseille et ailleurs c'est le
narcotrafic et il y a des milliers de
points de dî la France est en train
d'être gangrainée et on veut vraiment
avec cette commission d'enquête 1 là
encore faire un constat voir quel est
dans l'écosystème du narcotrafic la
place de la grande criminalité et sur
surtout proposer faire des propositions
pour avoir des vrais remèdes on
n'éradiquera pas le narcotrafic en
quelques jours parce que je pense que
ces racines désormais sont profondes en
France on veut comprendre justement ces
mécaniques pour essayer de de couper la
tête de ces tidr qui menace la
tranquillité et la paix en France un
dernier mot sur les européennes les
républicains n'ont toujours pas désigné
le leur tête de liste et Hervé Marseille
qui en plus d'être le patron des
sénateurs centristes est aussi le
président de l'UDI et lui il semble
favorable à une liste entre l'UDI et la
majorité présidentielle est-ce que ce
serait dommageable pour la majorité
sénatoriale moi j'ai toujours pensé que
la majorité sénatoriale c'était pas la
majorité présidentielle dans tous nos
votes d'ailleurs faut faire le calcul et
on n'est jamais d'ailleurs dans une
opposition pavlovienne on est dans une
opposition que je qualifie d'intérêt
général c'estàd qu'on essaie toujours
d'être utile pour pour les Français moi
en tout cas je pense que on veut porter
j'espère que ce sera notre tête de liste
François Xavier bami un projet qui
véritablement défende les intérêts
français vous savez je voudrais
simplement dire que le groupe de
Monsieur Macron euh et je voudrais que
les sénateurs centristes l'entendent en
Europe et au Parlement européen se sont
opposés à un certain nombre
d'amendements que nous portions le PPE
notamment qui est le parti de droite qui
est le premier parti au Parlement
européen notamment pour renforcer les
protections aux frontières contre
l'immigration à deux exceptions prês ils
on ils ont voté contre et pareil sur
l'inclusion du nucléaire la plupart
monsieur campfin qui est un macroniste
qui est président d'une grande
commission d'ailleurs au Parlement
européen et lui aussi n'a pas nous a pas
faciliter les choses donc moi ce que
j'observe c'est que le groupe RW le
groupe RW à Bruxelles est un groupe très
à gauche mais donc qu'est-ce que vous
lui dites Marseille de faire une List
commune avec vous ah moi je préférais
bien sûr on fait cause commune ici au
Sénat je préférais qu'on fasse aussi
cause commun et du coup ça aurait des
conséquences si jamais il va avec EMU
Catou je dire que là la vie est
suffisamment difficile en France pour ne
pas ajouter d'autres dimensions à notre
vie politique nationale merci Bruno
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
politique on va reparler du projet de
immigration et de la marche contre
l'antisémitisme tout de suite dans le
club